let's try and take care of these sick
people and not go to jail there's a full
spectrum of reasons lab testing is great
the POS wards for interesting over the
past few years Alma is the adult use of
marijuana after proposition 64 which
legalized cannabis in California for
adults over the age of 21 somebody with
like you know stage 4 cancer they could
spend forty dollars and get an edible to
last them the week that was in milligram
that will cut into squares you know and
now those don't exist anymore so that's
getting that same thousand milligrams
now stupid money what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
Saucon we are at the new West Summit
which is the world's leading cannabis
tech conference we have the pleasure of
sitting down with Jimmy Devine what's up
man how are you thank you so much dude
appreciate you super awesome you know
always trying to share that cannabis
knowledge new West is one of the best
places to do it for sure you know very
much it was it's still cutting edge but
like you know new West 1.0 like was at a
time when you know the idea of a weed
tech conference was like it made so much
sense and like to get you know the first
time those those kind of tech thought
leaders in the room together that kind
of thing and just what's transpired from
there that's so much fun every time yeah
this is this is a major key so jimmy is
a senior staff writer at canvas now
magazine and also writes for other
publications as well and you just made
the point that new estimate 1.0 until
now 4.0 this has been a process since
what is that 2014 yeah so and cannabis
has evolved you know so much since then
and you've been writing about it now
with cannabis now for two years but for
a long time the first time I was
published was way back in the day like
oh wait was about like policy stuff
mostly around weed and financial aid
stuff like you know like when
Massachusetts decriminalized Scott Brown
who went on to be senator Massachusetts
when there's still state senator who
want to recriminate in a car so you know
I would
I argue that you know that's just
creating a new mechanism in the middle
of the financial crisis is oh wait in
the middle of a financial crisis
creating new roadblocks to education you
know it's not how to solve our country's
drug problems you know I'm saying so you
know and then just the financial aid
thing kind of I got out here for the
English got out to the industry you know
nine and in Berkeley one of the most
progressive cannabis spaces in the
universe for the last decade just trying
to you know absorb as much information
as I can and I've been really lucky to
see a lot of the people who are killing
it today like make their way to the top
and just like it's been so fun to tell
their stories you know it's a beautiful
thing yeah and all right let's let's
unpack some of the like okay so from
2008 9:00 until now it's been ten years
there's been a lot of craziness that's
happened in both decriminalization as
well as legalization medicinal purposes
the use of this in medicine medicinal
purposes just technology evolving within
the industry with the science there's so
much that's going on and you write about
this so frequently three times a week
you're publishing a piece yes so why
don't you kind of walk us through what
have been some of these major sort of
pillars and milestones and fields that
have been evolving over the last decade
in the cannabis in well you know it's
like one of the things I point to is
just you know the customer experience
from like 1997 I use 2008 as a number
but that's a blurry number you know it
was all about you know let's let's try
and take care of these sick people and
not go to jail you know I'm pulling it
for you you're pulling for me it was a
very homey vibe like all the P one who
had the actual stones to open up shop
like we're pretty for the most part
we're very interconnected you know
Americans for safe access like the
support network was they were each
other's support network and you know it
Berkeley has another example with
medical cannabis commission like you
know seeing businesses take take it upon
themselves to kind of you know guide
guide their this industry in the most
responsible way possible at the smallest
scale is you're talking about you know
when you talk about Northern California
are talking about three the oldest
regulated cannabis markets in the world
in Oakland Berkeley in San Francisco
separately even if they were you know
we're
weren't all next to each other you know
and so just like regulation regulatory
incubator that I've got to watch
firsthand you know you know steep hill
lab started you know the lab lab testing
started in Oakland like a decade ago
like a real deal like part like
meaningful like you know the meaningful
kind you know is affecting us the way it
is now a decade later also have you
potentially explained to us here because
lab testing itself is extremely
important because we can find we can
find mold we can find
cannabis we can test the strains for
specific cannabinoids etc and those can
specifically help with illnesses so many
you know it's a full spectrum of reasons
lab testing is great no no you're not
[ __ ] poison knowing why this cannabis
is affecting this ailment that I have
the way it is like those those are the
two main fantastic ones and you know
Reed as we've seen recently in
California the lab - you know the labs
tell the story like with the fit
according to a recent report from the
Bureau of cannabis control a lot of the
failed test results are saying they're
not it's not because it's poison in
people's weed in those pesticides and
stuff like that which there is there's a
bunch of people to fail for that but for
the most part it's people failing
they're failing the labeling standards
of the state so it goes to the lab it's
not as good as they said it was but then
there's obviously you know all the other
societal consumer safety plethora of
great reasons and hopefully you know
it's been tough with the labs this year
getting caught up with this new market
you know 150 percent demand across the
state that all had to go through these
laboratories and then you had the
standards that hit on July 1st 2017 that
was a whole nother wave of you know kind
of bottleneck times for people and it's
you know that's it's a growing process
for everybody and you know we're
obviously pulling for the labs to you
know do the best they can with it Ben
some of the you know you just made this
really cool point about this Oakland
Berkeley San Francisco kind of like
triangle and what have been some of the
craziest you know progresses in
regulation that we've seen that have
enabled people to get their medicine
it's
etc well you know even though even with
that with with what happened with
California compassion programs in
California you know this is still like
the backbone these Berkeley Oakland the
San Francisco dispensaries they were all
taking a huge hit right now because the
product that they're giving away to
these you know hospice patients little
kids with seizures you know there's a
whole wide variety of people being
helped that that product has to enter
the system the same way that a product
that's gonna be sold to any given person
is and the whole person the whole point
of Senate bill SB a twenty nine the
Jerry Brown vetoed a couple weeks ago
was to create a mechanism within the
regulatory framework so that that
medicine would be under kind of like a
different tax code when we hit the same
way as all that stuff that was going out
the front door like you know with you
know for recreational purposes medical
purpose all that other stuff whatever
but you know the for the hit that people
are taking on the free medicine they're
selling this rough for sure but you know
kudos to those who do it anyway you know
bite the bullet and you know just
working continue going to continue to
work in Sacramento to find a solution
and as a lot of people have have faith
that our next governor could revisit the
issue so we'll see yeah all right so oh
my gosh there's so much to still like
understand let's talk about Tech's
influence because you know regulations
all like it's so much nuance to unpack
with regulation it looks like we're
moving towards a standard of
legalization across many countries in
the world and even states which is you
know fantastic maybe even before we get
to tech I want to hear your opinion on
this what is the proper way to maybe
ease I know everybody's different but
what's the proper way to East somebody
into cannabis so that they have a good
experience with cannabis so that that
it's not the safety is there you know
you know I probably go with a nice you
know
hybrid you know I don't want to give
them no like panic attack trainwreck
y'all want to get on any purple punch
that's gonna like stick them to the
couch you know depending on how you know
the person's mindset you know it could
be really negative experience first I'll
give them something you know I think
it's enjoyable fun
and milligrams you know I think that the
milligram thing is kind of like an
artificial barrier on the industry it
kind of makes it it takes out the
competition of who's going to give you
the most bang for your buck if everyone
has to put the most in so that kind of I
personally feel that the milligram
interesting kind of artificially
regulated the market and kind of hit the
consumers in a way that no they can't
get the most bang for their buck cuz
like lastly you know you drop to
December 31st somebody with like you
know stage for cancer they could spend
forty dollars and get an edible to last
them the week that was in milligram that
will cut into squares you know and now
those don't exist anymore so that's
getting that same thousand milligrams
now have to spend stupid money and then
the taxes on top of it presuming that
they're not a member of the MMIC card
program which so few people are it's
stuff okay yeah that makes sense the the
they used to be able to take these big
like kirova bars and black bars and they
could take these thousand milligram bars
and chop them up into small pieces and
then that's what could help them with
overtime forty dollars for helping them
with stage four cancer now it costs so
much more because of the regulation
that's very interesting I do still
wonder though like kind of like you know
is like one of those little three
milligram like tic tacs like is that
kind of like an interesting way to like
ease
somebody into like oh like how do you
how does your body feel now after an
hour in the day like I used to suggest I
would recommend when the fact the first
generation Korova products they had 150
milligrams childhood cookie dough people
take this cookie cut it in half and just
you'll be fine you'd be fine it might
not even you might need more you might
need you know it might not it might not
do it but I never I never had anyone
come back and be like oh my god
everyone's always like I'm gonna go back
look you know so it is what it is I you
know it's it's preposterous to me that
the the market doesn't have access to
really the dope quality few hundred
milligrams stuff that it did in the past
and it's it's stupid and it only gives
it
creates a mechanism within the black
market for something to do okay teach us
about you know the panel that you
moderated was about technology and
cannabis and there was you know IOT
Internet of Things there was VRA our
blockchain there were so many of these
different people representing different
parts of Technology that were entering
into the cannabis space artificial
intelligence what do you what have you
learned from them and where do you see
like what are you writing about within
technology in cannabis like one of the
big things with cannabis tech is even
though you know it's a new industry like
this you know when it comes to like a
lot of these solutions inventory stuff
you know business management stuff like
the wheels already been made a few times
and maybe sometimes there's a race like
people trying to rebuild the wheel and
you know so where is there there's this
balance that totally exists between
repurpose ment of things that have been
used successfully in other industries in
innovation that's obviously going to be
needed like so I think the question I
wish I could answer is well you know
where is that balance point so on and so
forth it's it's a wild one you know why
don't you unpack that just a little bit
more for us because what I see right now
like you're saying is I see so many
different technologies that have been
made that can just be repurposed into
cannabis and then there's like an
unneeded amount of trying to like make a
new wheel for the for the cannabis
industry whereas it could almost be like
what is completely new that hasn't been
innovated that can work for the industry
maybe give us some of the examples as
well of where you see the artificial
intelligence kicking in people having
experiences like we know of a friend
that has a meditation experience for
cannabis for augmented and virtual
reality I think yeah I think with AI
once you get it to like the main thing
that's going to be once it's tuned in to
the pot like the way you're looking at
it when it's gonna the way AI it's gonna
be able to look at the data sets like
that's the most immediate thing I would
imagine you know a lot of people talk
about blockchain it's tough like outside
of inventory control I could see the
dia of creating a coin or something like
that a mechanism that stays with a plant
or like some and then that coin can
break down you can cut that coin up and
it can go with each piece of inventory
that traveled from that plant like that
makes sense if you it seems over-the-top
to me but it makes sense to me as well
I'm a tougher sell on weed weed coin I
cos stuff like that like initial coin
offerings but like repurpose like
blocked repurposing blockchain for like
super advanced inventory control like
you know maybe like for somewhere like
Utah like I could see that having a
decentralized and immutable digital
Ledger's a fantastic way to keep in
track of really high caliber goods yeah
on that are in the cannabis space a lot
of people use QuickBooks until they had
to get set up for track and trace and
metric you know what I'm saying and it
was fine like taxes were paid on time
everything was fine like you know what
I'm saying
so like the the POS wars for interesting
over the past few years for sure seem
like teen companies try and position
themselves to be the top of that market
but pride are those guys who are very
still it's still very new thing like
comparatively you know everyone's just
using QuickBooks it was fine
like you know I'm saying like so it's
it's a repurpose mint is a cool thing
because then you can use it you can
really use your time to innovate if you
don't spend your time innovating things
that are already been done well you know
what I'm saying so that's I don't want
to sound like a hater but there's like
there's a quasi line that I don't you
know I wouldn't claim I could walk it
but it's it's that I side with you on
this is really important to figure out
where to invest the time into moving the
industry forward as optimally as
possible and I sometimes yeah just
adding a thing to the wheel isn't
necessarily the best way you you
mentioned the race in point of sale
people see like a lot of money to be
made there
in point of sale that's why they want
the you know to be the point of sale at
all the dispensaries they want to have
their software there where else I want
to know where else do you see the like
kind of like big-time races in the
cannabis industry cannabis in tech
separately from the tech side
distribution because everyone wanted to
be the guy of course verticals play a
big role in everything like they're kind
of off in their own little island so we
don't think about it
how much great pot is you know attached
so like vertically integrated processes
and all that jazz but once you talk to
people trying to get in recently
that's a distribution battle and it's
trying to get the best we possibly
possible to distribute to various
dispensaries and some people because
it's tough to go against like killers
you know what I mean there's people been
doing that they've been growing banging
house weed for a decade and it's like
what why do why do I want you some
guides like I've never seen in my life
to be the metal middleman you know what
I'm saying so it's it's it's a battle
but some people falling off you know
saying because there's a bunch of people
who wanted to grow weed got in the mix
in recent years you know and they you
know they need someone to distribute
this [ __ ] to you know everyone could you
got remember I think the vertical cutoff
was like June 1st 2016 was if you were
like set up by then you could like
vertically integrate for what was come
even if legalization didn't pass even if
it was just the medical marijuana
regulations like Mercer and all that you
would like that it would have looked
pretty you know a little pretty similar
to what it looks like right now like you
hear a lot of people playing and blaming
Amla for everything in the in the world
and you got to remember what was in the
pipeline with Mirza was gonna look
pretty similar to and from enforcement
sense from you know the the way the bar
was gonna be raised and what um and
mersa oh I'm sorry Alma is the adult use
of marijuana after proposition 64 which
legalized cannabis in California for
adults over the age of 21 and mersa was
the medic in I hope I get it right it
was like the medical cannabis research
and Safety Act there's another word in
there I'm missing but it was that was
like a few years ago and that kind of
was
to regulate the industry a bit a bit
more than it had been in those great
times once things cooled off you know
because also the state didn't want to
have a bunch of books on people like as
supportive as California was and you
know not everywhere you know there's
pretty hater surfs the state didn't have
a bunch of books on people if the feds
came calling like maybe you know Obama
didn't work out you know but
nevertheless know so you know eventually
things got to the point where the
regulatory system and the aura of safety
was there enough to hold the industry to
a higher standard
out beyond the Board of Equalization
saying that you paid your taxes so this
is this is important so this is like
creating legislation that helps us with
medical safety research as well as just
being able to just legally be like this
is cool for adults over 21 to possess
and smoke what happened was mercy passed
and then Alma passed and then they had
to be merged and since Alma was the will
of the voters Alma was supposed to beat
out Marissa when they collided like on
the one like it's specific subject
matter something there's some debate
does that always happen you know there's
a lot you know this is still a
contentious topic like because the whole
point of it a lot of this was to try and
bring the industry into the light not
create a new one
and it's some people say that that
that's a tough sell that that's happened
and I I would be it would be tough I
wouldn't I wouldn't start the debate
against them because it's definitely a
lot of hill kids up there that thought
they had the ducks in a row and thought
that you know even what would it would
be water rights whether it be
municipality they thought they had a
good shot that are in tough and tough
shape right now
yeah be it you know fires whatever
regulations you know a lot it was just
it was a tough year and hopefully you
know once everything settles out a bit
more and the landscape levels out like
people like still have a shot to like
you know that family farm that existed
for 30 X years still has a shot to be a
part of the market you know yeah wow
there's so much nuance here and there's
so much history
here and now we're kind of moving into
like this is a future of cannabis
Congress so give us your give us your
kind of your favorite favorite thing
your favor strategy your favorite future
part of the cannabis industry where are
you pushing your marbles where are you
pushing your attention why are you
interested in a story like if I had to
pick a story I could break I guess it
would be once things are a little bit
more set up at the federal level who
knows how long that is I'm not as
optimal as some folks uh optimistic as
some folks but there's something to be
said that all these Canadian companies
are positioning themselves super well
for the long term of course of course
but once American money is able to
really hit the market like really come
in like full-scale like I'm curious to
which company wins that race like who's
the first like American company to just
like do i dominate on a 50 state level
like without fear of repercussion
anything like it's just that down those
guys and they exist probably already
yeah it's just see how seeing him
walking that's another thing you've
watched how people you know like I said
I put that have put their ducks in a row
like in the most responsible way
possible a lot of people who did did do
they hit they hit it big like it wasn't
it wasn't it wasn't all sad stories and
you know just keep home for those folks
and hope more people get a shot I think
that what jury's pointing to especially
for you guys at home to think about is
you know this is all about foresight
it's about knowing that cannabis is
exploding in the United States and even
across the world and it's really
important to to think and innovate ahead
of time in this industry what are people
gonna want what are the businesses gonna
need what is the scientific process the
media process going to need and how can
then we build out the right
infrastructure and strategies to
potentially become there's gonna be
billionaires that are that are come out
through this industry because they're
the ones that are in all 50 states that
they're not worried about repression
and there's gonna be and there's gonna
be you know some really super hyper
boutique stuff to the people in like
it's gonna hold its price point fee is
stuff like that you know it's gonna be
crazy how it all comes down in the end
in the Walmart brand yeah they already
exist you know they like there's a lot
of crappy pot like I would argue a lot
of the candidates getting introduced
into the market is you know subpar you
know for like what we could be doing at
scale if everyone really did it with the
passion and love you see from the people
that have put their lives into it you
know yeah awesome that that was that was
as nuanced as we could get in a short
conversation with you so so much to
unpack still about cannabis
check out Jimmy online where can people
find you easiest at Jimmy divine Jimmy
divine comm links gonna be in the bio
we'll have it in the bio for you guys to
check out and as you guys know go and
create go build go manifest your destiny
into the world keep an eye on the
cannabis industry and how you can
potentially be a part much love everyone
thanks for tuning in crush on producing
super high end cannabis and
[Music]